[Music]
computer-generated effects are
ubiquitous in Hollywood so when
something amazing happens on-screen
audiences usually as soon as seeing a
digital fantasy but despite the surge in
CGI some directors are still committed
to doing special effects the
old-fashioned way before today's digital
wizardry existed from purpose to
prosthetics to old-school camera tricks
we rounded up some of the most insane
scenes you'll never believe were created
with our computers flipping out fact
director Christopher Nolan actively
disliked CGI and believes that audiences
prefer the real thing as much as he does
so he uses practical effects in his
films whenever possible
remember that epic car chase in the dark
night that ended with a giant 18-wheeler
going but over teakettle right in the
middle of an actual city block
[Music]
special effects genies use computers to
edit out some of the equipment involved
in the stunts but everything else was
completely real aided by a
remote-controlled piston that was
installed in the truck to propel its
rear off the ground
the scene was phone from seven different
angles because when you make it an
18-wheeler do a somersault in the middle
of the night in downtown Chicago there
is no such thing as take two antigravity
fists Iike the Dark Knight director
didn't limit his commitment to practical
effects only to his Batman franchise
which don't forget also included
blessing a plane in half midair a your
master plan
crushing this bird in Inception no than
an esteem created the gravity-defying
dream within a dream fight scene by
channeling none other than talented
singer and hat enthusiast Americo and
Bill 200 foot long hotel hallway on a
rotating set according to actor Joseph
gordon-levitt's the filming process
required as much mental flexibility as
it did acrobatic balance telling eonline
had to think of it like this is the
ground ok now this is the ground and now
this is the ground it was just that the
ground was always moving under me that
was the mind game I had to play to make
it work with a camera mounted on a track
that run the length of the sets no man
was able to create seamless stable shots
even as the hallway itself spun 360
degrees but Nolan wasn't the one who
invented the old rotating room the blood
barfing bed CGI wasn't much of an option
back in 1984
especially for a low-budget horror flick
like Wes Craven's my mare on Elm Street
so when Cravens horror franchise
introduced audiences for the original
fedora wearing monster they had to pull
off its nightmarish special-effects the
old-fashioned way these days the soul
sucking blood geysers are consumed
Johnny Depp would probably be done with
computers but for the original nightmare
the effect team came up with an
inventive way to pull it off the bedroom
sets was built on a rotating axis which
could be turned a full 360 degrees what
you see is actually an upside-down set
once the bedroom was flipped all they
had to do was pour 500 gallons of fake
blood through the bed and let gravity do
the rest
simple right men becoming wolves an
American Werewolf in London featured
animatronic heads prosthetic body parts
and the most elaborate assortment of
merkins in the history of film werewolf
iconic transformation scene was achieved
with nothing but good old-fashioned
practical effects and the magic of Ricky
Baker the effects bureau created
prosthetic versions of actor david
Norton's limbs then fitted them with air
bladders to make them deform as Northam
character turned for manse the wolf for
the facial transformation through
animatronic heads created the illusion
of the actors head reshaping itself into
something more wolf like and the furry
overcoat that affected user latex skin
threaded with thousands and thousands of
wire
have Baker film the hair being pulled
backwards through the skin and reverse
the shaft to stimulate rapid growth the
final result was so realistic and
terrifying that had earned its creator
the 1982 Academy Award for Best makeup
and when the movie got it's inevitable
21st century reboot in the form of an
American Werewolf in Paris the terrible
CGI effects couldn't hold a candle to
this practical wizardry but killer t-rex
hold on to you but there's a reason the
lizard king of Jurassic Park was such an
imposing presence he was a real-life
full-sized animatronic that nearly
killed someone on set the t-rex weighed
9,000 pounds and was built on a skeleton
made of hydraulic motors and the moving
metal parts
he was also decidedly dangerous during
the production a crew member was unlucky
enough to be stuck inside the belly of
the beast during a power outage sending
thousands of pounds of hydraulics
crushing down on him fortunately he
lived to tell the tale
even the digital dinosaurs of Jurassic
Park were often a combination of CGI and
puppetry for instance the Brachiosaurus
needs to lay the legs was only a digi
sore from the neck down
the head was all real for most of its
climb on screen as was the copious spray
of dynast not much to the dismay of
actress ariana richard little hobbits
big world rather than rely completely on
post-production CGI to shrink Elijah
Wood or am big and Ian McKellen Peter
Jackson often used old-school optical
illusions to make his Hobbit teeny tiny
in comparison to all the Wizards orcs
and elves of middle-earth using camera
angles cropping and the actors relative
positioning the effect known as forced
perspective makes them appear to be
differently sized than they actually are
in theory it's simple in practice it
meant that many shots had to be staged
down to the millimetre throughout the
entire Lord of the Rings trilogy as well
as the Hobbit trilogy a decade later
liquid metal evil in 1991 Terminator 2
was a groundbreaking example of the
power of digital effects boasting CGI
that went miles beyond anything else
that had been done however what made the
movie so spectacular wasn't the CGI
alone but the way James Cameron
seamlessly integrated the computer
animated cuts with practical effects for
every purely digital shots of t1000
slithering around in a liquid metal form
there was a scene render the
old-fashioned way
with puppets and expert camerawork
giving the film a sense of real world
weight most incredibly every time the
t1000 was blasted apart stan winston's
special effects team would bring in a
mangled metallic puppet complete with a
cast of actor Robert Patrick's head to
thrash around in the t1000 last moments
the blown up puppet is so seamlessly
intercut with motion capture effects but
you can't even tell where one ends and
the other begins
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]